[Music]  Leah Remini in tears after winning her  first Emmy very grateful and et spoke  with the actress backstage along with  former Scientologists Mike Rinder on  Saturday after their big win for their  AME docu-series Leah Remini Scientology  and the aftermath you guys did I mean  how are you feeling in this moment very  grateful and emotional yes and  appreciative of everybody that has  supported this show and all the people  that were willing to stand up and speak  you were neglected and abused just gonna  get bigger and bigger and bigger I want  to keep going until we see some justice  and I know in your acceptance speech you  really said some sweet candid things  about your mother how do you think she  feels right now has she expressed that  to you how you react she's probably  crying yeah there's just a lot of  emotions right now but it's very  grateful very grateful thank you so much  where we put in our Emmy dinner  cry in the center right center yeah  [Music]